So I always have had this
really I guess dual interest,
both in the fields of
technology, and computer
science, and electronics, as
well as life science research.
Where do we put the balls?
Pinball definitely feeds
a lot of my interests
just in terms of being able to
play with physical machines.
And I don't know there's just
something so pure and elegant
about what a pinball machine
brings to people simply
because you have two buttons.
You're trying to control one
silver ball bouncing around
in this environment.
And if I can ever make any
of the software systems
that I designed for life
science research as easy
to use as two buttons, and also
be as immersive as a pinball
machine can bring, then I have
succeeded at doing something.